[Musique]
nicker est un champion en herbe est
l'héritier d'une longue lignée de la
race rouge des traits un peu bougon
beaucoup de caractère il n'a que deux
ans et déjà un joli pedigree
pourquoi c'est une graine de champion
c'est un fils digne du renne qui a été à
paris deux années de suite et un petit
fils de fêtards qui a été le taureau le
plus lourd du salon de l'agriculture est
le plus lourd du monde
ils étaient trois années de suite le
taureau le plus long du salon est une
année record du monde à 1950 kg dans
quelques jours ni qui sera le plus jeune
taureau à concourir dans sa catégorie au
salon de l'agriculture à paris est une
fierté pour cet élevage
car sa graine de champion est un pur
produit de la mer les critères qui vont
être jugés vendredi c'est le dessus des
pôles le dessus des pôles la longueur
l'arrondi de culotte la couleur de la
robe
les apps l'ombre qu'il est bien les
aplombs bien poser c'est un animal qui
aura de la valeur bouchère plus tard et
ses descendants ont de la valeur
bouchère arrêté à la pesée aussi le
jeune taureau affiche déjà ses
prétentions leur déjà mille cent vingt
kilos à deux ans et déjà c'est déjà une
grande performance
les ja frais sont éleveurs depuis trois
générations sur les murs de
l'exploitation familiale des trophées
affiche la couleur
ici on est des bêtes de concours celui
qui m'a le plus marqué vers l'entente
286 et royal a été champion du monde
mais nous étions à paris quelques années
avant puisque on y va depuis 90 donc on
a eu deux des vaches championne en poids
et en toutes catégories confondues
encore quelques jours de répit pour
mickey
avant sa première scène
avant le tumulte et le fracas de la
compétition